welcome uh Happy New Year to planning uh
Committee of statford on aen District
Council my name is councilor Lewis Adam
I'm your chairman for this
evening um I'm going to run through some
housekeeping first and then move on to
the agenda uh there are no fire alarms
planned for this evening so if it does
go off please um make an orderly exit
and the must point is the car park by
the pub across the road um please make
sure your phones are either off or in
silent mode so they don't disrupt the
flow of the meeting uh this is a meeting
in public not a public meeting uh which
means that only those registered to
speak are permitted to do so um I will
call those registered up at the correct
time and give you further instructions
from that point um the meeting will be
recorded and broadcast on our website
I'll now introduce the top table from
democratic Services we have Cara Keller
um our sister this evening is Sue
Mullins our planning manager is Dale
Barker and our planning officers are
Allison Willers uh Malvina iik and Paul
Thompson and Dale I believe you got a
statement
prepared yes thank you chairman my role
tonight is to provide impartial advice
and to assist members in their decision
taking thank you chair thank you very
much okay we can now move on to the
agenda um item one apologies for absence
we have apologies from councilors
asander pton and Parry with councelor
scorer as substitute thank you very much
uh item two disclosure of Interest I'll
start and say we've had had um
circulated to all committee members um
Communications on items four and five
from interested parties uh and I think
they will have a blanket dispensation
for that uh go to counselor
passingham yeah I've got an interest in
that I'm a chair of a biodiversity group
that uh Strat on for that manages a
wildflower Meadow and also I'm a
director of Heart of England Community
Energy company that manages 60 Acres of
of solar farm that is managed as a
wildflower Meadow so but I'm but I've
got a completely open mind on this and
and I haven't uh haven't made any
judgments on it yet thank you very much
oh sorry what which item was that for
presumably number four yeah okay thank
you uh councelor scora thank you
chairman uh I'm just a non-pecuniary
interest in item six nor uh Norton Manor
Norton gr little Kinton I'm the parish
counselor
and also the District counselor um on
both I've made no
representation uh and although that the
parish council is speaking tonight um
this was done uh where I didn't attend
the meeting thank you and I come with an
open mind German thank you very much
councelor scor uh councelor Harvey thank
you chairman um I'm registered to speak
in relation to items four and five and
so we'll be vacating my seat and and in
relation to item uh six uh to avoid any
perception of um malfeasant or or
accusations of making decisions when I
shouldn't I will also not take part in
the discussion or decision on that item
either thank you very much any further
disclosures no okay we can move on then
to item three which is the minutes um so
we need to confirm and sign the minutes
uh for meetings held on the 22nd of
November I take everyone's had
opportunity to have a look agreed and
the 6th of December same everyone agreed
y okay jolly good all right we can now
move on to our first item then which is
um item four application
23148 ful um I have been informed by
officers that we have had an update with
regards to this um in addition to the
update sheet
um uh information regarding the uh
collecting of the ecological information
um is wanting in terms of determination
of the application on that basis the
recommendation from officers has changed
from Grant to defer so that further
information can be gathered so that we
can determine the application with uh
all relevant information required on
that basis I'm going to propose that we
defer that item until such information
is provided to officers and they can
make an accurate assessment coun Ren
I'll second that chair thank you very
much anyone else like to speak on
that no in which case that item will be
deferred to the next available um
planning committee once the information
has been
received okay um we can then move on to
item number five which is application
23567 ful the barn new B Mill M lay new
bold on Stow our presenting officer is
Malina itic and uh Dale has uh want to
just run through the update sheet uh
before her
presentation yes thank you chair um I
what we've done in the past when we've
had long updates is we've said to
members would you like five minutes to
read the updates I'm thinking rather
than do that tonight it would probably
be be better and members would
understand it better if I run you
through the up dates and point you to
where the changes are uh if if you want
to do it another way you only have to
say but I'm I'm I'm trying to do it to
to make it as uh straightforward as I
can for you so we're looking at
Corrections uh which is beneath
consultation responses if you look and
it's saying on page
36 so if you could turn to page 36 of
your report you have a look in the One 2
3 4 fifth parad paragraph down halfway
through the paragraph it says how
however I
note and we're updating it as the text
in your update sheet however I note that
the northeastern and Northern edges of
the site specifically parts of the
proposed rear Gardens to plots two three
and four areas of approximately 10 by 80
and 9 by 50 M lie outside the bab of new
Bal and Stow as defined in the
NDP so that's significantly more
land then moving on to paragraph eight
of the same page three further down uh
the whole paragraph the proposed
dwellings will be located wholly within
the defined bab therefore I find no
conflict with policy H1 of the NDP in
this regard however parts of the
proposed residential Gardens are located
outside the
bab and
then are we all there have we all found
that then moving us on to page
37 second
paragraph
and the second line starts whilst the
garden whilst The Gardens of plots 2
three and four extend beyond the
built-up area boundary I consider that
the development overall complies with
core strategy policies cs15 as10 and NDP
policy H1 I do however consider that it
is reasonable to recommend a condition
which would restrict certain permitted
development rights on plots 2 three and
four to ensure that any domestic
extensions and out buildings are
carefully considered by the local
planning Authority in the future should
the application be approved so it's just
retaining control of any extensions or
out
buildings moving on a a new paragraph
should sorry some of the proposed
Highway Improvement Works appear to be
located outside but adjacent to the
adopted bab of new new Bal on Stow these
Works would improve the highway safety
therefore would bring public benefits to
the area and are overall considered to
comply with the provisions of the penel
ultimate paragraph of as10 furthermore
the encroachment would not be
significant and the visual impacts of
those are not considered
harmful in the light of the above it's
recommended that condition 23 which is
at the end of the
report on
page
46 should be extended to include
conditions two and
three
and then backtracking a little page
39 first
paragraph where the density is stated as
being 27 dwellings to the
hectare uh there was a sticky key on the
keyboard at least that's what we're
claiming It should read seven to the
hectare I do apologize for
that moving on further to page
43 and Counting
down excuse me to paragraph 7 1 2 3 4
five six
7 excuse
me uh page
43 please note that an updated flood
risk assessment was submitted the the
report is is simply a little unclear
there was an updated committee flood
risk report submitted which takes into
account the reduced number of dwellings
from 5 to four as uh during the the
evaluation of the application in all
other respects that paragraph is
unchanged so that the flood risk
assessment is
acceptable and then finally moving on to
page
44 paragraph four again halfway through
it says policy CS6 of the framework new
sentence however the submissed submitted
biodiversity impact assessment proposes
to offset against the loss of
biodiversity in the adjacent field by
enhancing and protecting the area for
Ecology biodiversity and local habitats
this area of land is under the control
of the
applicants and that's all the The
crucial updates for you
members and those Corrections do not
affect the officer's
recommendation so I I hope that made
sense if members have got any questions
on the updates please shout if not we'll
move on and Malvina will will do her
presentation no
queries take it away thank you thank
you good evening thank you
chair
[Applause]
um uh the application site is located in
New Bolton Tower as denoted by the Black
do um on this
plan the application site comprises of
land associated with the with a
residential dwelling uh the barn uh
located within M lane two Residential
Properties are join the site uh from the
south and east uh with reverse Tower to
the north of the
site
um planning permission is sold for
erection of four number of detached
dwellings and Associated development
including improved uh vehicle
access um this plan uh is rotated um as
you can see the barn is
here
um
the next two slides uh will show you the
proposed dwelling types and
finishes above you can see plot one and
plot two
below plot three
um and plot
four just
there um now going to the photographs
this Photograph shows um the host
dwelling so here is the barn uh looking
towards Mill
Lane beyond the
dwelling and uh the closest neighbor
Orchard Drive beyond the tree line
there this Photograph shows
you uh the burn again looking towards
the neighbor to the east at the millhous
you can see the neighboring garage
there and it is worth noting that the
builda paria boundary um sort of
ends where the garage uh building
starts and this Photograph uh shows the
site looking in the opposite
direction uh so you can see that the
Gans of plots 2 three and four um would
be
there uh chairman the recommendation is
to approve the application for planning
permissions subject to to the conditions
as detailed within the committee report
and the update sheet thank
you thank you very much okay we now move
on then to our first Speaker who is
councelor Trevor Harvey um on behalf of
tredington Parish Council
good evening counselor uh so at this
juncture you've got three
minutes I'm happy to give you a 30
second warning uh before your time is
up okay otherwise uh when you're
comfortable take it
away thank you chairman tredington
Parish Council objects to this
application because there is no
demonstrable need for for these four
bedroom houses in new bold the housing
needs surveys conducted in 2013 and 2020
both Illustrated a need for affordable
houses with an emphasis on Bungalows
this application meets neither
requirement the plan development
breaches the boab and infringes on the
flood plane some 40 houses have been
built in mid lane in the last few years
runoff has increased dramatically and
this and the sewage pumping station has
had no expansion to cope with the
increased demand more houses will make
the situation worse M Lane is a single
Track Road currently with no passing
places the access to and from Mill Lane
is dangerous Hedges have not been cut
back resulting in the required sight
lines not being in place even though the
30 mph limit has been in been extended
to the south of mil Lane traffic still
passes at excessive speeds past the end
of the road the lower part of mil Lane
is an unadopted private road and is
maintained by the residents no
consideration of this appears in the
supporting documents the NDP policy H3
makes provision for housing as long as
it does not introduce an inappropriate
form of development at odds with
existing settlement patterns and does
not significantly and demonstrably harm
the Amity of the of the most of the host
dwelling and that of neighboring
properties this application
significantly impinges on the character
of the adjacent dwellings especially the
Old Mill NDP policy B1 states that the
proposals must be compatible with the
distinctive character of the area
respecting local settlement pattern
building styles and materials and does
not increase the likelihood of surface
water flooding this application does
neither the claim that the application
meets the provisions of NDP policy ne1
is not acceptable the provisions for the
ecological offset for this application
is
flawed regarding core strategy as10 this
development will have a detrimental
effect on neighboring uh areas and
neighboring amenities a once rural Lane
has been overdeveloped already with
large multi-car households being built
for these reasons the parish council
believed this application should be
refused thank you
chairman thank you very much councelor
um members do we have any questions for
councel Harvey councel h serin Hello
councelor Harvey um You referred to the
housing
survey um are there any four bedroomroom
houses on the survey needed at all no no
okay thank you councelor
scora thank you chairman councelor um
you mentioned the Sur in Newbold would
you know if there's been any CSO
discharges uh into the river
sta I can't answer that question but I
do think that that question could be
asked of a subsequent
speaker thank
you any further questions for councelor
Harvey no no which case thank you very
much
councelor okay we now move on to our
next speakers who are Stella Khan and
Michael
yes certainly um if you'd like to just
both take a seat um it's so to turn on
the microphone it's the button on the
right hand
side um okay
um sorry I just turn the turn the
microphone on sorry um I didn't want my
time to start now no it's fine I just
wanted to check that all committee
members have received the statement that
I sent in on
Monday uh yes I believe so and that was
part of the dispensation we had at the
beginning great thank you and yeah
apologies Mr Andy Clark is it yes yes
yeah sorry and um so what what I want to
do is just uh give my speech now and
then show so so can you actually can I
sort of uh um so in in terms of the
procedure so the officers can um bring
move through the the photos if youve if
I just say next yeah precis they'll do
there and yeah so when you're ready I'll
start time would you like a 30 second
timer just let you know when your time
is up right okay this application should
be refused on the basis that it will
increase the risk of flooding elsewhere
contrary to CS4 Part B and will have a
negative impact on water quality qu
contrary to CS4 Part D I have sent you
evidence of increased flash flooding
cumulatively after each new development
on M Lane I have sent you evidence of
the severity of this and the impact on
our quality of life and risk to Life
Health and property I have sent you data
showing that Flooding at our home and
two neighboring properties has increased
from an average of one in 10 years to
greater than one in two years following
Mill Lane developments I have sent you
evidence that your case is based on
hearsay an out ofd flood risk assessment
modeling from the environment agency by
their own admission I have highlighted
our concerns that the existing sewage
system is struggling to cope with all
the extra development and I have sent
you evidence of river pollution and
toilet paper on the River
Bank the propo sorry there are no drains
inst installed along the length of Mill
Lane to deal with surface water the
proposed widening of the tarmac laning
footpath will compound flash flooding
risk above that POS by the four new
houses alone again this contravenes
CS4 on the matter of sewage capacity the
case officer has dismissed our concerns
on the basis that seven Trent has not
raised any
objections the the factor of the matter
is that southern Trent has failed to
comment at all importantly policy CS4
conflicts conflicts with seven Trent's
response to us Waste Water waste surface
water will be kept out of the sewage
Network wherever possible and there is
no longer an automatic right to connect
to the sewage Network given the poor
reputation water companies have over
legally discharging untreated sewage
into rivers 7even Trent was fined 1.5
million pounds for sewage discharges
into worshire residents and the
environment demand so much better than
this and I would like to conclude with
some slides here of our guard
this is before developments on mil Lane
when you can see what we call minor
Garden flooding from the river star at
3.6 meter
sorry okay next slide post development
at a lower level of 3.3 M look at the
difference that's major flooding to our
garden which goes into our house despite
flood defen defenses next slide please
this is an example of 2019 where we had
River Stow levels at
3.69 and most of our ground floor was
affected so front room dining room
utility room I'll ask you to wrap it up
there next next slide I've only got
literally that's just showing the
neighbors uh the barn site okay which
was okay next slide uh sorry we'll we'll
leave it there that's it that's the last
one thank you we we'll have have the
slide left up and that's fine um at this
point I'll ask members um if they want
any questions for you and you can
elaborate then as as as required uh
members do we have any questions
councelor
Keely thank you chair oh good evening St
thank you very much um very interested
to see those photographs to be honest um
would you be able to take us back a
couple on on there could you
explain before any development one of
your earlier photographs you showed
there was very little flooding and a
little bit in the the
garden and the river level was much
lower have you had any experience before
the development of floods that have come
into the house as you've demonstrated in
your subsequent photographs well in 2007
was the the catastrophic flood yeah so
that obviously was we we've been there
since
1999 right and 2007 was the the one
flood that we had before developments
yeah and that presumably at that level
that excessive level that did come into
your house absolutely absolutely it was
up to waste high right okay but since
then what you're saying is that you've
had regular flooding incidents much more
frequently and then these are the
examples from these folks yes much lower
levels I mean we've we've got these
which is obviously information I've sent
into the council and to the committee
before but we've got these readings from
shipston on Stow Gage so that we've
meticulously put this evidence together
right and it shows that we now flood at
Le more than one me to less at River
star levels than we used to before
develop could I ask if you've had any
correspondence with seven Trent over
these issues and any responses have yes
I'm sorry to sound like this but I am
fed up with writing and and calling
seven Trent I have asked for records um
of backed up sewage and callouts to our
property um they they they tell you that
they're going to send things you don't
you just get generic responses um and
nothing more okay um and that leads me
on to in our grounds we have a
CSO we we have the the sewage uh pipe
the main sewer that feeds the village
which I believe the bar this bar
development will will attach to right
runs through our grounds right and we
have an overflow pipe into the river sty
which is the toilet paper that I showed
at the
end so we every month we have seven
Trent or its subcontractors coming out
to to our grounds a lot of the times
they're having to jet wash it because
we're backed up sewage into one of our
own toilets as well and so it's a
disgrace to us that seven Trent have
failed to respond at all to this
application and the case officer or the
SDC don't seem to think that is
necessary following our concerns we also
don't
understand we just have to make sure
you're only answering the question that
have been proposed thank for next thank
you thank you chairman I'll ask the same
question as I did to the the ward member
uh do you know how many csos were um
discharged uh last uh last year in our
grounds no I don't because we don't
check it all the time I mean you know
it's in our padic so I don't go running
out to check our padic all the time it's
it's and and so the data I did want to
uh to get from Seven Trent but they have
not been forthcoming I I I can say that
this morning I actually went to the
outflow as because uh uh as a community
volunteers Up and Down the River are
taking uh River samples for nitrates and
phosphates and while I did that today
and I've taken a photo of it there was a
sanitary towel on the on the the bank
there that had just just go through
again uh would would the parish council
know I know it's very difficult to uh
get that kind of information from seven
Trent but I know some par councils have
got that information uh would your
Parish Council have they looked into
that no I mean I I
I no thank you very much U just for
reference I asked officers to um put up
a plan of the local area just so I was
clear on exactly where we were talking
about in reference to your photographs
um do do you mind me asking just which
which property is it that we're that you
uh that is yours that the photographs
were taken
from
um where the arrow is is it mil house
yeah that's mil house yeah yeah so we're
pointing at it with the and we've got a
neighbor at the Mill MH yeah thank you
very much um okay members any further
questions no okay in which case thank
you all very much for your contribution
thank
you um okay so our next speaker is
Miranda Rogers agent for the
applicant good
evening uh so you've six minutes I'm
happy to give you a 30 second
warning um otherwise uh once you're
comfy uh take it
away am I
working
good okay so this application ised
proposing the erection of four detached
dwellings within the BB for the service
Village of new Balon Stow the principal
Accords with the core strategy cs10 B
which supports smallscale housing
schemes within the boab of local service
Villages your offices are recommending
approval indicating they have no
concerns regarding acknowledged
interests not withstanding your
officer's strong support for the
proposal you have heard there are a
number of objections um starting with a
matter raised on Monday by the occupiers
of Orchard Drive which actually hasn't
been raised so far so I'm not going to
say a great deal about it other than to
say we are content that all the
submitted drawings are correct uh and
the extent of the application site is
accurately plotted and also to say that
all notifications to owners and
surrounding residents have been
accurately made uh not least because the
application was advertised in the
statford herald uh which is unusual for
application of this nature because
nobody knows who owns all of the drive
down to the bottom of the road so to
consider the various objections firstly
incursion into the countryside each of
the proposed dwellings itself will be
situated wholly within the boab for new
Balon St parts of the gardens lie in lie
Beyond but that land is already in
Garden use your office's report
addresses this matter with reference to
an appeal decision from 2020 where
dwellings were proposed within the boab
for little Kinton with Gardens outside
the inspector concluded that in this
instance because the dwellings would be
within the bab there would be no
conflict with the development plan or
with national planning guidance your
offices propos removing permitted
development rights for outbuildings and
extensions to plots 2 three and four to
ensure there will be no development
outside the boab in fact this would be a
benefit because at present land is in
Garden use and out buildings could be
erected uh additional housing not
required in the district councelor
Harvey has indicated in his written
submissions that additional housing in
newold is cont to policy he refers to an
appeal decision for erwood where an
inspector concluded the housing figures
in policy cs16 were seen as a maximum
this is a surprising appeal decision as
there are many others that you will
probably be aware aware of which
identify housing figures as minimums or
approximates your offices refer to one
such recent decision in wford from 2022
where four additional dwellings were
allowed on appeal regardless of the fact
the district had met its housing figures
in policy cs16 and significantly
exceeded them in wealth it itself the
inspector noted references to the words
approximately and around to show that
the policy does not intend to set a firm
upper limit uh the housing figures are
not therefore to be seen as maximums
where PR and where the principle of
housing otherwise complies with the
development plan as in this case there
is no policy
conflict uh not meeting local housing
needs you've heard that the proposal is
contrary to policy 82 of the
neighborhood plan because it provides
only large Market dwellings and not
small houses to meet local housing needs
policy H2 does not apply to this
proposal as it is not a smallscale
community-led housing scheme adjacent to
the BB there are no policies that
prevent Market housing within builtup
area
boundaries harm to Road users various
objectors have been concerned with the
increase in traffic associated with the
development thinking it will cause harm
to highway safety warsh County Council
has assessed The Proposal confirming
that the widening of the road to 5
meters and the provision of foot paths
as proposed will not cause any adverse
impact on highway
safety increased risk of flooding from
surface water
runoff we've just heard that local
residents believe that there is an
increased runoff down Mill Lane
following heavy periods of rainfall
since the development of marting gal's
and Green Acres with this proposal which
is what we are considering there will be
no increase in surface water runoff on M
Lane resulting from the development of
the dwellings the flood risk assessment
confirms that an underground Cellular
store will be installed to hold any
additional water allowing release only
at existing Greenfield runoff rates and
then only towards the river and not
towards M Lane I acknowledge what was
said about there being no surface water
drains on M Lane itself water from the
widened Road could be directed under the
Road and into this development and
therefore into the Cellular store
inadequate file drainage capacity I'm
not going to say a great deal about this
because you've heard Lots perhaps it's
only worth saying that if you feel that
the existing system is inadequate not
that seven Trent has said that then we
could alternatively Implement on-site
storage and that could be
investigated uh neighbor Amity uh the
office's report assesses each dwelling
and confirms all necessary separation
distances are met to ensure there will
be no harm to neighbor immunity uh and
biodiversity offsetting yes the proposal
will result in the loss of some trees
from the site the applicant proposes to
use other land immediately to the east
to compensate and provide biodiversity
enhancement overall this proposal will
create a high quality development which
reflects the character and appearance of
the area at a density which is
consistent with the immediate locality
the scheme Accords with the development
plan and in the absence of material
consideration
which indicate other wordswise I would
ask you to Grant planning permission in
accordance with your officer's
recommendation thank you very much well
within your time uh members do we have
any questions for our agent for the
application C
kethley thank you chair um good evening
Miranda sorry I was for some reason I
was looking over there I apologize oh
it's me look I've got the red light
there was a red one over there was there
okay um particularly interested in your
your um comments in resp respect of
surface water flooding and potential
mitigation um could the officer put up
the last plan that went up do you think
I'm trying to understand where cellular
St how how the surface water runoff on
this site relates to the neighbors's
property we've just seen photographs of
and where the water would go from this
site the surface water runs in North
almost a Northerly direction if you look
at the land levels you will see it
slopes quite considerably at the edge of
the proposed built up area boundary
going down towards the river right so
surface water is directed that way
towards the river so when I look at that
cuz this has turned around 90 so if
you're looking at that plan it's going
yeah so if I look at that in that red
block what you saying is that the
surface water tends to run north towards
the River from there that's where it
will be going as a result of this
development and the neighboring property
we've just seen the photographs of is
which one down there yes exactly where
the arrow is pointing is is that one
some
some pardon okay thank you for that no
interjections from the the public
audience please thanks very much
chair uh any further questions councilor
passing was looking in the right
direction um you said that uh if we
considered that the sewage capacity
wasn't adequate you could install uh
local storage well we can have um
package treatment plants to suit these
four dwellings if appropriate right I
mean and so far we've not been told from
Seven Trend that this development cannot
be handled through the existing
treatment plant so this would be a mini
surage treatment plant really you'd have
on site individual for the four
dwellings right and um are you are you
sure that that would well we need to we
need to find out whether that would be
with I think that that kind of proposal
is used for an awful lot of rural
developments where there are no main
sewers it's common place to see them
implemented so I have no reason to doubt
that it wouldn't work in this location
particularly given the size of the the
plots and the space around to sink a a
tank thanks thank you I do have a
question myself um with regards to the
plan that we're looking at uh on the
screen can you tell me which direction
the river flows I don't know the the
area at all go that
way so to to the to the left to the left
yeah okay thank you yeah West okay uh
any further questions from
Members no in which case thank you very
much for your
contribution move on then to our final
speaker who is again councelor Harvey is
the ward
member welcome back uh you've got five
minutes at this
juncture um again I'm happy to give you
a third to second warning if you if
you'd like no okay no Reas thank you
very much take it
away thank you chairman this application
should be refused for a combination of
six reasons notably it proposes
development in the open Countryside
contrary to as10 it would increase the
risk of further flooding contrary to CS4
the type of housing proposed doesn't
meet a local need contrary to housing
policy H2 of the NDP it would further
skew the distribution of housing
contributors
cs15 it would exceed the volumes of
building for an lsv 3 specified in
cs16 and the district already has the
third highest land Supply in the country
at 14.55 years the officer's report
states that one area of the proposed
Garden area lies outside the bab she
cites an appeal decision in little
Kinton to support her recommendation
that this application be granted the
officer's report is incomplete the basis
of the inspector's decision is
questionable the little Kinton
application involved two houses and a
single incursion into the open
Countryside this application proposes
four houses and three incursions into
the open Countryside this application
can therefore be distinguished from the
little little Kon application first by
its scale second the inspector held in
that instance because the dwellings
themselves were located within the boab
the fact that the gardens were in the
Countryside did not give rise to a
conflict with the requirements of the
local strategy this is an unduly narrow
and somewhat strange rationale cs9 deals
with design and distinctiveness the
supporting sdp provides that the minimum
size of garden for a four-bedroom
dwelling is 62 Square met so without the
inclusion of a suitable and integral
Garden space any such application is
likely to be refused for non-compliance
with
cs9 if such a garden is in the open
Countryside and if it doesn't provide
significant public benefit as is the
case here it fails the test of as10 it
follows that it should be refused these
factors distinguish the circumstances of
the barn from those of the little Kinton
decision for the purpose of this
determination therefore it should be
disregarded the barn application
proposes three separate incursions into
the be UAB on this ground alone it
merits refusal Dr khah has presented
evidence that this application fa would
fall foul of CS4 there are no drains to
deal with the surface water installed at
any point along the lane along M Lane Dr
K's evidence supports her case that as
development has taken place along M Lane
in recent years so the level of runoff
surface water has increased this has
resulted in increases in in the level
and frequency of flash
flooding it's predictable that any
further development in M Lane is likely
in the words of CS4 to increase the risk
of flooding
elsewhere the officer has relied on a
reply from the environment agency which
is based on 201 2010 data that is
manifestly out of date despite the
accelerating impact on rainfall levels
of climate change the tredington NDP
housing needs survey provides evidence
that there's no need for any additional
four-bedroom houses in new bold what are
needed are more one and two bedroom
units particularly
Bungalows as an lsv newold as an3 new
bold was required to provide for around
around 58 dwellings to comply with the
requirements of cs16 it has actually
already provided
106 I draw the committee's attention
ention to the inspector's decision in in
March 2023 in the case of Lander erwood
common involving another lsv 3 where he
stated it should be noted however this
figure I.E 58 is a maximum finally I
merely point to the council's current
land Supply level at
14.55 years there is no planning policy
imperative that militates in this
application's favor to conclude Mr
chairman the facts and the evidence
demonstrate that this application does
not comply with
cs451 16 as10 nor with policy H2 of the
NDP the committee has firm planning
reasons for refusing this application
and I urge it to do so thank you
chairman thank you very much well with
the time uh members do we have any
questions for our Ward
member councilor
Fleming you mentioned that uh the one
survey was from 2010 how many houses
have been built down mid lane since
2010 one development one development of
35 and one development of five so that's
40 houses okay so things have changed
dramatically since 2010 then uh they
have changed dramatically and the use of
Mill Lane itself as a result of those 40
houses has changed because not only you
get a greater conflict between local
traffic that was there farmers and and
people who live for down the lane but
you now get uh um parents with push
chairs children with with bicycles you
still get horse riders there's a a great
conflict of of use along Mill
Lane any further questions C Keithley
thank you chair evening councilor Harvey
um just in respect of the um the gardens
being outside the builtup area boundary
and um the discussion that you gave in
respect of the findings at Kinton how do
you respond to the
agents um position that the land in
question is already residential
Garden can I draw an analogy with a
decision taken by the council not not
very many weeks ago uh up the road in
Old Acres old acres is is the
development on the other side of Orchard
Drive where the the householder bought
the plot the bottom part of the plot was
outside the buildup areial boundary he
moved his fence so that he the fence
aligned with where he thought he'd
bought I that element of the garden
which was beyond the builtup area
boundary uh enforcement was involved
enforcement said you need to move the
fence back to the built-up area boundary
he said I don't want to do that
enforcement said well the only way you
can regularize that then is to put a
planning application in to extend your
garden beyond the builtup barrier
boundary to where you have the fence so
he did and the application was refused
why because there was no public benefit
for the extension of change of use from
agricultural to Garden I I just don't
see the difference between saying on the
one hand we'll defend the where the
builtup area boundary is in that case
and in this case simply
saying it doesn't matter that on three
sides es this this development will
incur into the built up into the open
Countryside beyond the built-up area
boundary I don't see the
distinction please only to say that I'm
I'm assuming that the the reason there
isn't an argument about the residential
Garden currently extending Beyond The Bu
of Barry boundary was because it was in
place perhaps before The Bu of barrier
boundary was
drawn um well that's not true on two
sides it may it may apply to the the the
Eastern side but the northern side I the
bottom of that diagram and the and the
top of that diagram where the path is
intended to be put uh that that argument
doesn't doesn't hold doesn't hold water
it's not the right thing to say in this
context is
it thank you counselor uh any further
questions for our W
member no in which case thank you very
much for your contribution this
evening okay members uh we'll now move
on then to points of clarification from
our officers any point of clarification
we'd like to
raise counc
pattingham um it's it's quite obvious
from the photos and from other things
we've heard that the sewage system is
not adequate the ex for the existing
housing in
Newbold um and uh the to uh to um so is
is the the lack of a sewage system and
in effect adequate infrastructure a
planning reason for
rejecting these
houses thank you councelor excuse
me um so um it is acknowledged that um
sever
Trent was consulted and did not make any
comments
um however on that basis
um we couldn't conclude that the
existing sewage system is
inadequate obviously um from from the
representations uh it appears that there
are some issues but um a condition was
recommended to secure um full um f and
uh surface water strategy to be
submitted um um so um this this issue um
could be resolved by attaching an
appropriate
condition so if the condition was to
install a mini surage treatment PL would
would that need a further planning
application and are we sure that would
uh be approved uh I mean would it could
you make a condition even though you
don't know what they're going to install
whether it would be
adequate chair through you if I may
um the drainage Authority have control
here if they cannot reach agreement with
the developer to connect to their
drains uh they will not accept sewage
the developer will then sewage rather
sorry the developer will then have to
find another alternative which will be
to submit an application for a package
works and only if a package Works can be
approved as a separate planning
permission excuse me sorry do we say
separate planning permission or do we
say condition um condition condition
yeah so only if it's acceptable by
submission of information to comply with
that condition can they build the
package seage treatment works so we have
control both ways if it connects to the
main sewage uh then it's controlled by
7even Trent if it's connected to a
package works we will receive details
which we will then get agreed by the
relevant drainage Authority right
so we possible say I'm afraid not no we
we've gone past the point of public
contribution thank you so we could put a
condition on this application that they
install a mini seage treatment plant
because we don't think the seage system
is
adequate just looking at our legal
advisor I think that would be an in
appropriate direction to take agreement
of the means of disposal of sewage uh is
appropriate telling them they must do it
one particular way is inappropriate and
I'm getting nods from over there even
though we know that um there's an awful
lot of sewage over spills in we have
been told that we don't know it CH could
we re defer the the the application
until we find
out C of passing them well if you don't
mind we'll sort we won't have too much
debate between s members and officers i'
want s points of clarification for for
fact um broadly speaking um are there
any other points of clarification that
um have Arisen from the uh what we've
heard so far councilor Keith Le yes
thanks chair yeah point of clarification
on the builtup area boundary and the
fact that the gardens are outside the
builtup area boundary now we've heard
from the applicant that it's already a
residential Garden
um but this is a fresh application for
some new houses and their Gardens go
outside the builtup area boundary so I'm
confused as to whether or not in fact
there's a um potentially a reason to uh
refuse this because the gardens are
going to be in open Countryside can you
help me understand that
please
okay uh the ward member councelor Harvey
talked about three areas in which uh
this application was extending Beyond
builtup area boundaries let's deal with
the first the easy one first it's the
footway along M Lane uh the proposal is
to to construct a footway along Mill
Lane and technically that is beyond the
build built up area
boundary uh I officer's view is that the
construction of that footway will bring
considerable public benefit because
it'll make it safer for people walking
along M Lane and we don't see that as an
issue which leaves us with two
areas there's an area at the bottom left
of the application site in white and
there's an area at yes I don't know
where you describe that not quite the
bottom left in
white the the latter one point to it
again the latter one that one yeah uh we
can show you some photographs of it in a
moment it it appears to currently be
used as part of the garden of the barn
we've checked the planning history and
we can find no evidence to show that it
has planning permission for use as
Garden but we've also checked uh Google
Earth going back over a 20-year period
and it seems quite clear that it has
been used as Garden for 20 years uh as
members will know if you can demonstrate
that a piece of land has been used for
10 years for the same purpose people are
entitled to a certificate of lawful use
we're we're working on the the
reasonable assumption that a certificate
of lawful use would be available for
that parcel of land that that is in
practice Garden which leaves us with the
final parcel of land there which marvine
is pointing out which appears to the
best of our our knowledge to be
agricultural land we can find no uh
reference to any application for for for
planning permission to use that land for
anything does that answer the
question yes I think so it would
probably be helpful for me to understand
the red line that Malvina is just
pointing to now this this side yeah yeah
that's the extent of the application
site is correct yes so in fact the
gardens for
two three and four are pretty much in
agricultural land according to that
which would be open
Countryside some of yes well significant
part of it probably in open Countryside
okay yes that answers that question
thank you very much
indeed do any further questions for for
officers yeahor I I do uh have
another uh question and that was really
about the housing needs survey and the
as I understand it the tredington U
neighborhood development plan is fairly
recently made would that be the
case and that the housing needs survey
would probably be included in that we've
heard from um some evidence from the
floor about the fact that um people feel
there's already far too many houses and
that that lane has been already welld
developed how much weight can we place
on the housing needs
survey um so um in respect of
establishing whether the principle of
this development is acceptable or not uh
um as the planning agent previously
explained um um the core strategy
policies do not require this development
uh um to meet the local need um and
um I think that's we can I think that's
that's all hopefully this answers your
question
councelor um I have a point of
clarification I'd like um to be made uh
with regards to the access road the
highway that um in this case is noted as
being outside the bill up area boundary
U with a Le Red Line boundary um there's
reference in the report to a previous
application under the highways um part
which
needed uh I think it was conditioned to
improve the highway along that that line
but that's um not presently built out um
how how's does that sit in relation to
what's being proposed here specifically
with regards to how it sits outside the
the boundary as
well uh so um the previous application
uh required the highways uh improvements
to be implemented namely um if I
remember correctly passing um base and
and um uh currently they do not appear
to be implemented and um um the
enforcement team is dealing with this
issue however it is uh clear that the
passing base uh along with the new
improvements that are currently proposed
uh um are required by the highway
Authority um to to make the development
acceptable from their point of
view but the development isn't yet
complete is it yes it it does not appear
to be be uh fully completed okay thank
you any further points of
clarification Council Fleming did you
have a point of
clarification already done okay in which
case we can move on to debate who would
like to
start Al I shall start picking on
people counc Eden thank
you thank you chair
um I feel uneasy about this one I'll be
honest um I think councelor Harvey made
a lot of very good sand planning points
in his various uh
speeches um my main concern is
definitely around the built-up area
boundary piece and obviously the
flooding of the residents um we have two
policies that stand
up in defense of both of those um issues
um and I'll listen to more of the debate
uh
having got it off and
rolling but I'm kind of leaning towards
stand U using those as a way of um
resisting this one
myself thank you very much who would
like to go next councilor
Fleming echoing something that councel
Eden's been saying um this this flooding
issue is a is a thing and having sort of
in my own Ward um a lot of over
development that's caused ongoing issues
this seven Trend they never ever refuse
they never say no they say when there's
a problem we'll fix it sometimes that
takes a long time to do um so that's a
big issue for me and the fact that uh
these these neighbors and existing sort
of uh householders are having to put up
with this flooding thing on a more
regular basis um that deeply concerns me
uh the open issue of the uh open
Countryside with a with a builtup area
boundaries and whatever is a concern and
just at this moment in time having
listened to councelor Harvey give the
various reasons he has um I don't think
at this point I'm going to support the
officer's recommendation and uh so but I
want to see what everybody else has to
say first thank you very much anyone
else counc thank you chair yeah I have
concerns about this application and I
think councelor Harvey's put it over
quite well um there is no need for four
bedroom houses um also I have concerns
of the flooding and um going into the
open Countryside so I'm very uneasy
about this one thank
you thank you Council
passing yeah I'm I'm concerned and I'm
I'm very concerned about this the sewage
and it's a nonsense that seven Trent can
say that it's acceptable when seven TR
to allow so many spillages into into the
river Stow uh and uh we can't do
anything about that it seems um I'd be
happier if they if we could put a
condition on it to to install a Min
series treatment plant but at the same
time that it seems to be going against
the spirit of the neighborhood
development plant have a four four
bedroomed houses here where whereas it's
not it's not
um it's not stated in the anywhere that
the um neighborhood development plan um
needs them and requires them and there
are these other planning reasons which I
think valid as
well thank you councelor scor next thank
you chairman again I agree with uh uh
councelor Fleming um that I'm going
towards the I'm not agreeing with the
officer's recommendation three sides of
the plot is in open Countryside for me
concerns about the CSO I know that can
be um looked after with uh own surage on
site but I think you got to look at the
bigger picture as well being up
Upstream uh I think we have a
responsibility to look after our rivers
and I know seven Trent don't normally
make a recommendation but I still think
as councilors we have a a responsibility
to look after our fellow uh neighbors
Downstream
uh and also it's not in the neighborhood
plan of the uh the village so I think
I'll be going uh against the officers
recommendation okay thank you very much
I know we got other speakers uh planned
but I believe um Dale has just wanted to
come in on the flooding Point uh
specifically yes thank you chair um if
if members are minded to refuse this
application on the flooding issue I
think it's important that they take take
into account in formulating their reason
for for
refusal that we will potentially need to
demonstrate that the site can't be
adequately drained should the applicants
choose to
appeal and I don't think anyone around
this table has the skills to to develop
an argument like that and I don't know
any officers that have the skills to
develop an argument like that that's why
we use seven Trent and if seven Trent
are saying that they have no objection
then either it can be disposed of via
the existing sewage or it can be
disposed of via a package works and
we've offered a solution to that by way
of
condition excuse me uh I think the other
point that that I I I need to make is
there is an existing problem here and
it's not this development's
responsibility to resolve the existing
problem it's this development's
responsibility to deal with its own uh
waste now that that might seem unfair
that might seem unreasonable that might
seem un wrong but that is nevertheless
the
situation and I can't read your not
Note S Trent did not comment
yeah did I did I imply sorry I'll just
if I did I apologize I didn't intend to
imply that okay thank you I know they
didn't come in yeah councelor Keith next
right thank thank you chair and thank
thank you Dale that was uh that was
helpful I mean what I've heard is that
um the surface water yes I know there's
an existing problem with the with with
that area now because of the development
on mil Lane but this is a new
development where surface water's likely
to find a different way through to the
river so so I'm not convinced that
surface water treatment is going to be a
reason for refusing this and neither am
I convinced that um dealing with uh
sewage is either because the applicant
has got some choices it can either look
to to connect to the Main's system as it
is now or bring in a package treatment
works and that is for them to determine
with the waste
people um however um I have got some
concerns about the NDP and the housing
needs survey I hear that perhaps we
can't take that into account because
this type of development doesn't have to
refer back to the the housing needs
survey but it does seem like more big
houses in an area where there's already
a lot of development and the road is
under pressure but I think my principal
cause for concern is that we've heard
quite um clearly that um some of these
Gardens are going to be have to be
formed outside the builtup area boundary
in open Countryside and that is against
the NDP and it's also against as10 so if
we want planning reasons to refuse this
application my proposal would be that we
do so uh on the basis that um the
development of the gardens particularly
for those three properties is on
agricultural land it's an open
Countryside it's against the policies in
the NDP and in
as10 and that's a proposal to uh
refuse thank you councilor Keithley
um I think youve you've been quite
succinct I'll I'll add my my comments at
this point um I have to second on that
basis CU I I think the the feeling in
the room is along these lines but I
think we need to be exceedingly clear
about the reasons that we are giving for
refusal um and and make sure not to
include anything which can be open to
challenge um with regards to the
drainage I think you said it effectively
I'm incredibly uncomfortable that the
only evidence we have is actually from
residents who are suffering from issues
and have nothing from 7even Trent
themselves on that basis I don't
particularly have much faith in in that
area but I don't feel that we have any
um grounds to include that in our
reasoning um we do however have
incursions into the um open Countryside
outside of the builtup area boundary
which is plain on the plan and in
multiple directions I think that is
obenson is agricultural land one is
albeit
potentially um residential curtilage but
not uh defined as such at this time and
there's also another incursion on the
other side albeit that there is an
Associated uh reason for that um and
that's the reason so I'm happy to to
Second um would anyone else like to to
contribute to the debate otherwise I'm
going councelor
Holmes um yeah I was going to say is it
worth just focusing on Purely the
agricultural point if you are going to
um make a suggestion because I think
there was fairly um Su reasons why to
the west and to the north why that would
be
acceptable
thank you um okay I mean I think broadly
speaking we're we're we've got the sense
of feeling in the room and as to where
we're going we've got a proposal which
has been seconded um which would be
against uh for effectively
as10 um which I know that the officers
have taken down your
reasoning uh just wait was the
uh
speak
sorry CH we we just discussing
um
suggesting just
discussing our understanding of the
debate that members have had so far and
we are we are thinking we think we we
understand that the creation of three
Gardens that's plots two three and four
within open Countryside outside the
builtup area boundary is Contra contrary
to the provisions of as10 B and that is
the nub of your reason for refusal yeah
we understood that correctly brilliant
thank you
Char good um okay I don't believe anyone
else wanted to contribute to the debate
no uh in which case we yes we have a
proposal to uh refuse application uh for
the reason just stated uh can I see all
those in favor
please that's unanimous in which
case uh committee resolves to refuse
application
slfu okay thank you very much we're now
gonna have a change of Officer chair
johnly good we'll uh have a change of
off officer and uh come back to you
momentarily
okay um right then we'll now move on to
item six which is application
23269 ful Norton Manor Norton gra little
Kinton our presenting officer is Paul
Thompson when you're ready to take it
away thank you very much chair good
evening everyone happy New Year uh this
is an application for a stable building
including three Stables a workshop uh
Tax store feed room that sort of thing
uh in little Kon Norton gra is the uh
the rough area there um um this is the
application site in red uh Norton
Manor uh roughly Central in the image
and the blue outline is the remaining
land owned by the applicant on which the
applicant uh the occupants of the
proposed stable exercise and go about
their equin
business uh the parish council is
objecting to this development um and
because they raise in their objection uh
some references to to uh the builtup
area boundary and several other
designations I thought it would be
helpful if we see those on the screen
the application site is again in red or
rather not the application site to be
precise it is the area of land most
affected by the
development um that is the the red
outline the thicker red outline is St
John's Castle Mound that's a scheduled
ancient Monument or
Sam the green hatching is an area of
restri
uh which is governed by policy cs13 in
our core
strategy and the pink outline uh is the
little colington Conservation Area and
towards the bottom here from the
neighborhood development plan we can
also see the green areas which areas uh
designated as being sensitive
Landscapes uh hopefully that's clear
this is uh the development keen and
attentive viewers will notice that this
is upside down this is for ease of
reference because it's the same way as
same way up as the rest of the maps you
can see the north arrow in the corner
just gives you a bearing on where we are
um this the access through the site does
currently exist this uh outline in the
top left is uh is alleged to be the
remains of a building that collapsed in
the '90s
or 60s it's upside down I can't
tell um over laid here is something else
to which the Parish Council made
reference which is a development granted
permission on appeal in 2020 it's for
two dwellings rear of Norton Manor uh I
can't claim military Precision
necessarily but um this is broadly
speaking the relationship between the
proposed stable and those dwellings uh
which are not complete um the state of
play there is is unclear but is not
necessarily relevant or material here
here this is what is proposed precisely
uh as you can see Workshop feed storage
three stables and attack room with an
Associated yard um we have you'll note
in the report um I've taken on bridge
against the render finish um I propose a
condition prescribing that finish um and
requiring the submission of details um
this is an aerial photograph with
everything
laid uh you can see the uh vegetation
along the boundaries there the um rather
unhealthy I've just noticed this is the
right way up so uh
that's that's that strategy out um yeah
bonus um yeah so that's that's roughly
the relationship of the uh the site to
the existing buildings um the area of
restraint is to the South which is the
bottom of this image and that is a view
through the side looking towards the uh
the area that's going to be developed in
the uh top Center there uh again trees
along the boundaries uh that chair is
pretty much that um my recommendation is
to Grant planning permission on the
basis of what we have before us subject
to the conditions in the report thank
you thanks very much Paul okay uh we'll
move on to our only speaker then uh who
is councelor David goling from Kon
Parish Council
good evening councelor uh so you've got
three minutes and it's the Bott on the
right hand side just to uh turn the
microphone live I'm happy to give you a
30 second
warning and uh once you're situated uh
take it
away good evening counselors and
officers um I'm pleased to be able to
join you this evening to explain why Kon
Parish Council is objecting to this
proposal our objection is based on on
grounds of policy and principle cont
neighborhood plan was developed to
support the delivery of the housing
numbers determined by the core strategy
and today we've exceeded the minimum
number the minimum number um by nearly
26% um when a site with outline Planning
Commission is built out it will be 26%
all were within within the settlement
boundary the ethos of the plan was to
contain all development within that
boundary the planning officer is correct
when he identifies the specific policy
as applying to housing but back then we
were Keen to plan to meet the needs of
the district's planning policies even if
we had written in a policy to prevent
all development outside the settlement
boundary it would have been over Ren
overridden even by policies such as as10
as10 has been here all night hasn't it
we're keen to ensure that policies are
complied with and and I am pleased that
the planning officer has agreed with us
regarding ing most of
af10 however he then appears to override
the parts of the policy we agree do not
support this development with a sub
clause and the sub Clause refers to
development acceptable in principle if
for tourism and Leisure identifying
Sport and visitor Recreation and more
specifically if it would help to provide
local employment and support local
Services the applicant's design and
access statement clarifies that the
horses are already in The Paddock
they've occasionally escaped and the
stable is intended to prevent this but I
would have suggested a good fence might
achieve the same objective um and a
tractor is used for upkeep of the
paddock will also be stalled within the
new build stored within the new building
where then does the building of this
stable block provide local employment
and or support local Services any more
than is currently the case and where
does it deliver visitor Recreation to
encourage tourism as10 therefore does
not add any positive positive weight
sorry as10 section s does not add any
positive weight to a policy which the
application fails to comply with so we
ask you to consider the spirit of the
neighborhood plan and the clear intent
of the core strategy policy as10 which
defines what can and cannot be built
outside settlement boundaries of main
rural centers the proposed development
fails to comply with the relevant
development plan policy and please vote
to refuse this appliation should you be
minded to determine in favor of the
office's recommendation please ensure
that the note he proposes to include in
the consent regarding Mission creep is
included it does not appear to be on the
list at the end of his report thank
you thank you very much just in your
time members do we have any questions
for our Parish
counselor no nothing forthcoming in
which case thank you very much for your
contribution okay uh they that was our
only speaker for this item which means
we can move on to points of
clarification from our officers are any
points of clarification we're
seeking C Keith Lee thanks chair yes um
thank you very much Paul in your report
you make a note that there's a
possibility and there's always a concern
that although this is Agricultural
Development normally class Q wouldn't
apply to agricultural land that we have
had examples where class qes actually
slipped through agricultural land and
agricultural buildings seems to slip
through on class Q how are you going how
would we prevent
that a question question rather than
agricultural sorry question I beg you
pardon yes a question quite um yeah the
the simple um answer is that it's an
equestrian building as as permitted and
as proposed it would be an equestrian
building therefore class Q rights just
wouldn't apply so there would be no
means by which a class Q approval could
be sought on uh with on this building
okay thank you the other thing is when
you put the the plan up there was a an
aerial photograph probably Google Images
it showed some other buildings in near
proximity to it can you just describe to
us what's there
already uh I've touched on this in the
report I don't consider it to be
material in so far as I've taken the the
lawful and established use of the land
to be agricultural land or a question
I.E that it's a paddock of of some sort
um from my observations on site
and as stated in the planning statement
accompanying the application it's being
used to store uh building materials and
such like so it's a sort of um either an
ancillary domestic storage or an
ancillary commercial storage use I have
not found anything in the planning
history suggests that use has been
authorized I also have no information on
how long that use is persisted but the
structures you can see there are largely
associated with that there's a a small
poly tunnel some
um beds and and places for plants to
grow um so you're suggesting that that
this isn't potentially this is not
equestrian there's no lawful use of this
land for equestrian purposes now I would
say that the lawful use is equestrian it
may be that through the passage of time
this storage use is now lawful but we
have no lawful use certificate on that
or any information about how long the
use has persisted that might allow me to
make a judgment so on that basis i' I've
concluded that it is currently in a
question so silly question then are
there horses there at the moment or not
for the best of my knowledge yes
counselor can I just caution members not
to get distracted into other matters
we're considering the red line that you
see before you and the application
that's before you not something
else thank you any further points of
clarification
no in which case we move on to the
debate you would like to
start no one's jumping um councelor
Keithley you um made a point to get some
clarification would you like to start um
well I can start I don't I mean I think
the officer has written a very
comprehensive report I've heard from the
parish council but the office has
written that the um the development is
for for for private use it's a question
for private use it's lowlevel um use um
there's no impact on residential amuni
as I can I can read raised the issue of
the potential conditions in respect of
its use and also to change the
appearance of the building I do share
concerns about the possibility what
might happen in future but we can only
look at what's in front of us now so on
that basis I'm happy to propose that we
accept the officer's recommendation to
Grant thank you very much councilor
Fleming yeah and couple of things the
the objection uh counselor was saying
about principles and objectives and
these sort of things didn't have a
specific thing against this particular
development and like um counc Keithley
says this is a private a private
development really for their own use
doesn't have to conform to um uh
amenities for the for public imunity
should I say um so I'm more than happy
to Second councelor ke's
proposal thank you very much uh yes I
for my part I appreciate where the
parish council's coming from but in
terms of policy um items against it I
don't think we've got anything um
substantial enough to go against uh
would anyone else like to contribute to
the debate no in which case we have a
proposal that's been seconded to Grant
in line with the officers
recommendations can I see all those in
favor
eight
against one okay in which case uh
committee resolves to Grant application
F all
right
and
hold on a second um so um just to finish
off item seven urgent business no urgent
business in which case I can declare the
meeting
closed